do you have like a little 50 second wonder where I can talk to myself?
oh why not some stock in my head
I haven't even partaken in hot pants
oh cheers
oh
only ink, no cute real auntie
the sun's getting real low
you guys sound like Bruce Banner
hi
are we there?
did I hear myself double echoing?
there better not be a triple echo in here
mommmy
good morning good evening good afternoon
we are doing something very special
because in my two months of streaming so far
I've never done one a public watch along
and two a watch along of an anime
I'm gonna be a certified weev after this
not one of yous can call me a fake anime fan after this session
no I have watched some anime
don't get me wrong I have
I've seen like Attack on Titan season one
season one of my hero academia nuts
all that kind of thing
how's your service?
it's good
it's not sore today
we're gonna be traumatized from this fuck
right the reason we are watching happy sugar life
is because
drumroll please
it's a 12 episode anime
which means we can watch it all in one day
which is what I was aiming for
so we're gonna be sitting on our tushies
for about six hours today
how's your zip?
oh my zipple
my zipple's okay
it did exactly as I suggested
so there's a red outline from where it broke
in quotation marks
the zip for broke
and I've already been traumatized from this
fake gamer, fake weave, fake streamer, fake everything
even chats, pre-recorded
literally the streams are pre-made
everything's pre-made
it's a great show
well we're about to find out
I have my cup of tea
I was going to ramble
I was gonna ramble
I will go back in this stream
and timestamp exactly when the episode starts
let's be honest
I'm a bit of a rambler
come on now
it's me
a yug hut me
I only do this for male attention
you're absolutely correct
why do you think I only use he, him
in my scripts?
he made da males
ink right now
I have a refling that sits on my chest
during watch-alongs
cause I always have a refling with me
you will talk a lot during that
so we are
watching
sub
titles
sub titles
so first before we start
arguing
subs vs. dubs
I couldn't get less of a shite
you know what it's getting
it's getting
Xbox vs. Playstation fans
or subs vs. dubs
oh
oh but with sub titles
you get to listen to the real anime words
oh and the passion and the voice
oh right ok ok
oh but if you listen to
shut up
let people enjoy things that they enjoy
ok
how about that
how about let people enjoy what they want to enjoy
if someone is too tired to read sub titles
during an entire episode
or an entire series
god forbid they listen to the english dub
god forbid
forbidden
it's actually the 11th commandment
on the back side of the tablet
when moses came down that hill
and he went
you know he said
thou shalt not kill
thou shalt not da da da
and then actually there was a secret one
on the back of the tablet
and it said
thou shalt not
a fucking great
when someone debates on
sub vs. dubs when it comes to anime
and then in quotation
in brackets pardon me
it said
you'll understand this in about 2,000 years time
I don't know what to say
let people enjoy
thanks gade
but the dub says
skibbity rezz
ok we're watching the dub version
oh my gosh
mom
what about my skibbity rezz
for fucks sake
27 minutes ago
I recently said
on marshmallow
I command the
sleautistic pog
waifu
love heart
no that's not a good thing
starney don't you know
you lose
your weeb card
when you watch sub
for fuck's sake
and he's more rules
fuck's sake there's a 12th commandment
oh sorry
let me get the commandment back out again
and then moza said
right there's a 12th commandment mate
and he goes
there's actually a secret hidden room
and if you do watch in dubs
you'll lose what's known as your weeb card
again you're gonna understand this in about
2,000 years time
and then everyone in the town
slash village was like
what the fuck is he on about
but anyway
they just let it happen ok
I mean
shit that's
most of the history
most of the history is like
let it happen
and then until it becomes a real problem
and now it's became a real problem
2,000 years later
go down
eh
I already have mild autism
please don't make it severe
I'm sorry
you're gonna be bouncing off of me
like I'm bouncing off your cheeks tonight
actually you have to watch raw
with no subs
and no understanding
the only thing I'm gonna understand is
don't
alright my voice is so cracked this morning
eh
ooh 2 hours ago
hi Sturney, how are you feeling?
just a suggestion for the anime watch belongs
but can we make sure we take breaks of the 3-4 episodes
you want a break every 4 episodes deal
you're on I'll go stretch
haha
that's literally my only experience
is straight up like fan service anime
and no
I don't care if you don't count
monster misumi
as a real anime
I don't give
I don't give a rat's arse
okay it's a good series
I thoroughly enjoyed it
papi
number one
love papi
love my harpies
I'm getting a harpie
and gen 4 confirmed
I don't care what anyone says
monster misumi is based
I don't care if anyone says
eh
papi's flat chested
that's weird
I kill you
whoa
steady on
play minecraft in survival mode
how about that huh
how about hardcore survival minecraft
for you
eh
wow
some
papi gangbis
ehm
the gen
lol
strongly bringing our inner anime
real and true
mama going off today
sorry I'm like
I am both exhausted
I got 8 hours
I think
roughly
I don't know
I forgot to eat yesterday
and I basically ate a handful of crisps
and then I had two scoops of like
pre-made pasta
what else did I have
I had
a chug jug
of fruit juice
there's like
a glass of fruit
that has like all these
blended up
super healthy for me
eh
and a cheese string
because I forgot to eat
right before I slept
and I was like
I don't know
how I forgot to
ehm
eat
because normally food's
on my mind all the time
I'm one really good
you know
ehm
it's a pretty easy guess
we'll eat food in two
two minutes chose
okay
I'm gonna keep
rambling
that's right
what's that you're
you're eagerly
awaiting to press
play
on the episode
no fucking
I'm having a tea first
okay
you had too much ink
ehm
hey moment
sorry for dup question
oh my god I can't believe it
you have the audacity
to ask me a question
you're more than allowed
to ask it
please don't ever feel bad
if you ask a question
I've answered before
it is impossible for you
to literally
watch and consume
all of my content
all at once
I'm so sorry
but it is impossible
I get comments
from like
vods gone by
and they're like
I'm so glad I finally
caught up with this stream
and it was like
a month ago
and I'm like
oh I feel so bad
like I've produced
too much content
to keep up with
you literally
have the times to
the content
to keep up mildly
ehm
you've seen this in her wit
some refling something
that looks like a challenge
except keep yapping
I'm having internet
trouble right now
oh you want me to stop
what were you talking about
you mean your
your streaming service
that is attached
to your credit card
legal name and address
is ehm
struggling to
deal with the downloads
hmm
yes
yes your streaming service
how dare you
produce too much content
I can't believe it
the value you get
from around these parts
someone left a love part
on my foot count me
some more stream
ehm
this is where the chance is
the dolls
I love that stream
that was the hoot in the hall
I'm rewatching it
sorry I'm rewatching
my own stream
what my shrink watch
along got
in trouble
no it didn't
oh wait
we talked a lot
after the shrink one
now hold on a minute
oopsie
I've got my drink
yeah
right I said YouTube
you're reviewing
my hand cam stream
and my thigh stream
I just tell YouTube
to like
review everything
I'm sorry
but
you're not putting
limited ads on me
cause they took
limited ads
off of my role play
where I'm like
please let me
hold it
and I'm like
no
if we're playing these games
if we're playing
oh my god
my poor Lego lord of the rings
I'll probably just throw them
up to the edge
hehehe
got my drink
you've heard the lifestyle
board game
now introducing
the lifestyle
of YouTubers
Droneiko
cause I literally
take up all your time
unfortunately I don't
have enough time
to watch every
the new stream
as I said
it is not
it is not possible
in French
no no
sir
it is not possible
that is not how you say that
sense
I think it's
impossible
it's just probably
not correct either
sorry Emmy
if you heard that
my apologies
Emmy
sorry
I love this anime
so much
I've been looking forward to this
watch along
ah it's my first one
I'm glad you like it
I was surprised you guys
knew the name of it
but then at the same time
I chose me
I picked a decent one
cause it got recommended
for being so short
hey beautiful
just wanted
to let you know
the urge to commission art
of you
tied
to
override
the need for not dying
because I
unwillingly spent money
on a road trip
with my
fiance on our
anniversary
it's coming up
the guy I want to commission
does excellent
pair of bodies
I will see you
in spaz
what's spaz
also congrats
on your anniversary
what the heck
spaz
a shortening of
spatter dashes
or spatter guards
or a type of footwear
accessory
for outdoor wear
covering the instep
and the ankle
well
I'm commissioning a girl
to have that
what the heck
spaz
curious
congrats
on your upcoming
anniversary though
make sure you spend it on
you don't have to spoil me
I commissioned
something really degenerate
of me and my gen mates
already
I've got you covered
we're on the say
little handshake emoji
we're on the same page
I assure you
spaz are like
sports shorts
those type ones
oh
spaz are type boxers
uh
ok google told me
a fiver
oh
google lied to me
I'm gonna google you
so hard right now
google's always with you
I don't find much
drawing many things these days
but I've been enjoying
you and me allure
by extension
aww
you've kept me entertained
in my tentacle drain
aww yeah
oh my god
that's the riflin model
entertained in tentacle drain
amen
I love that model
I'm stealing that model
that model is my nephew
thank you
please do not hire a singer
for your next generation
oh go on then riflin
let's hear you out right
this riflin's talking
about gen 2
what's going on here
for the love of god
mummy
do not hire a singer
for your next gen
ok ok
they always put the least
amount of effort
into their live streams
and when making scripted
content
they phone it in
I'm not sure what they
phone it in
they like to act tough
but are just self important
it cannot
improv
or handle criticism
to save their lives
to the surprise of no one
they grow to dislike
their companies
fans in their own
and that one
guy
more than anyone
in the business
but nothing compares
what is this about
phone it in
means minimal effort
oh you're teaching me
you're teaching me things
I love being educated
I mean he's kind of cooking
this is so specific
wait is this specific
what does that mean
I must
wait am I not allowed to
say this out loud
what the sigma
am I saying something
the things are even
remotely passionate about
in brackets male singers
are not even close to
the kind of veal
or seeks to make
wait does someone make
a statement that they
wanted to join us or something
if a singer
auditions for veal
or it means she's looking for
a simp farm to buy
then her
comicale
expensive
dream microphone
and some other gear
she'll need to fill you
herself
he's being extremely
specific
oh no there's something
I don't know about
I'm getting
the tea
oh I literally have the tea
whilst I'm getting the tea
okay my apologies
I'm just reading
I'm just reading what I was saying
okay
look I hear all the reeflings
here I don't care
the reeflings are allowed to
vouch
I don't care if you call out
favoritism
the reeflings are allowed to
vouch
I don't give a shit
I love my reeflings
full stop
my reeflings love me
it is a good bloody life
together
I'm sorry I don't care
if anyone's like
you shouldn't let the reefling
conform to
actually the reeflings
for the whole reason
so maybe I will let them
influence me
I'll let them influence me
all the way up into my cervix
so
hope your nip naps heal
well
strongy
thank you
I'll be sure to kiss it
and lick it
perpetual cycle
of love real entry
talking about
stewie meals
what are you like chicken
potatoes and carrots
the three bases
you boil them
you mash them
you stick them in
okay
no
stop right there
criminal scum
get pampered
hi strongy
you brought up dub versus sub
I just want to give you
some background
okay we're getting some
history
old dub used to be awful
like genuinely bad
these days
they aren't so bad
but some og sands
might have ptsd
from those days
og sands
can we confirm
that your
dubs were
absolutely abysmal
back in the day
very
comfortable
okay I'm going to finish this team
we'll get ready to go
so can you grab things
now with a left nip
don't speak
for the next 10 seconds
it's healing
it's gone straight back
to exactly where
it was supposed to be
and I thought
that's exactly what would happen
because of the healing properties
of the area
nah
mad build out for dub
was great I suppose
so
you're older than me
you wouldn't let me
take advantage of you
no no
she melts the guys
in the morning
german dubs are mostly
pretty good
hello loiter
about skips
what would a german anime
sound like
ishbin
ishbin crying
little sister
I don't know
how to shove that together
cause you know how the anime
almost has a light voice
when you tell him
I'm so sorry
I didn't mean to
spill that coffee
one more
please let me
clean it up
oh yeah
you like that
mommy when you were a child
did you like
scottish dubbing
I'm so sorry
but that's not a thing
Scotland Dubs gets put in
the gutter
there's no such thing as
scottish dub
cause they never make it
ishbin
I am your little sister
as a german don't
ever mention
german dub again
Shawnee should do a stream
where you dub over
some anime
is my style
but that's not
what I'm saying
I don't care what you're saying
I just become toad
Scottish dub
it would literally be like
a candy date captain
it's a dilifium
crystals captain
they're just candy dates
people
people die
when they're killed
but be
what
but big brother
I put from there
now hold on a minute
okay one kiss for you I guess
I came out of nowhere
erin
oh you won the scottish version
of that
erin
we gotta get to the basement
sounded like toadstool from mario
I used to too
are you trying to
can't wait for you to
put the suppository in me
okay I don't want to
okay
I don't care what anyone says
suppository
then ties are the best
the way you pronounce it
it sounded like you said
I am your little sweater
like sweat
I need a brush up on my German
I didn't realize how many German
reeflings there are
so I need a brush up on that
shit real quick
oh joe lingo
time for a German stream
hello we get
do we good
yeah
natuurlich
oh wait that's Dutch
well I always end up
going to Dutch
cause I only know
fucking up
you're alive in German
prime time
it's 8 p.m. right now
Spanish or Vanish
can you do something
in your nose
natuurlich is German to
right
what
at that speed
I don't want
I don't mean to sound
insensitive
but if I just speak Dutch
did the Germans get it
like
hello
Ikeben
Stronikathels
Ikewoon
in
Australie
Ikebenen
apple sap
I don't know
I don't know I'm out of
I'm out of Dutch
I
literally just said
I am an apple just
Dutchies understand
Germans but Germans
don't understand
I don't understand
yeah your apple just
literally that's the best
apple sap
yes apple sap
Ikeben apple sap
it's even easier
to understand and write
and how curious
to see
thank you though
I wish it could be 10
10% as cool as
Shiro Emiya
Je he Ibe o Ema Ema
who are you
fictional character
also written as
Shiro Emiya
in fate of limited codes
is a fictional character
that the main protagonist
of 2004 visual novel fate
oh my god I was actually
how many languages
can you speak?
one, English
two on paper
technically because
Scots is legally recognized
Germans they seem to
have a word for everything
krankenwagen
anti baby pilling
oh my god
wait hold on
get me on google translate
right now
I'm gonna say one sentence
for the Germans and then
we're gonna play the
play the thing
don't worry I will time stamp
when we actually play
episodes
to take
okay and then English
put it into German
right now
and then the Germans
are gonna cry
and then
I must name an
anti baby pilling
riflin
did that make sense?
did it make sense
or did I just butcher
the crap out of your language
be honest
does it make sense
one cut is
it might work
I don't know
I'm just here for the good time
not for a long time
it was possible
wait you don't want my German to do this
I said I need to take my
anti
I need to take my birth control
rifling after the thing
bitchered but yes
that was good
right what other languages
do you rifling speak
I'll start saying random stuff
in it right now
English
okay give me your tentacle
there did you like that
English
you see
give me
give me a dining tentacle
Spanish
we got a Spanish
hold on
give me a Spanish
I don't say this
English
oh no no
that part is English
sorry that part is English
sorry Google translate
I messed it up
right
give me your tentacle
get ready
right
I was for the Spanish
hi
I don't know how to say
where is the library
Luxembourgish
Gaelic
I didn't even know Gaelic myself
we've got
Africans
that is Netherlands
by extension
you can understand me
that was Swedish
Swedish
oh Swedish
I'm gonna butcher you so badly
Gaelic
give me your tentacle
I'm Swedish
give me that tentacle
what is Luxembourgish
oh my god there's no pronunciation
for Luxembourgish
okay well
thank you
passable
Well, possible
Watch long yeah, all right, okay, right everyone get ready to press play on their stream surely you're all downloaded by now
It's been literally 24 minutes of yapping
French German
Johnny's fluent in Japanese truly, okay, right is everyone ready?
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say three two one go and on go you hit play
alright
Three two one go right got it right, okay ready, and we're doing it for real this time three two one go
Oh
What the fuck I thought this is an anime about two cute girls. Oh well there they are I found them
Monka
Am I watching the right is this opening?
Are we watching the same anime I
Love that little anime when they always like pan to someone
They love each other. Oh, did she kill her?
No, no, no, no, you can't use an opening and then go for the most Kawaii Desune fucking theme song are you trolling?
What is this?
No, no, no, no, no, no, you can't eat it at the house
If you like more than watch food wars, I actually watched some of food wars. I didn't finish it. Oh
My god, she's a lollicon
Oh
Let's escape together
This is so upbeat for whatever that intro was also they burnt the high table
None of it matters to me because I just want you I
Finished with food boy. Oh, I bet you finished that anime
This scrambled egg is glorious
Every episode was like that
And the screen is a bit
It's a little a little off-center. Can you forgive me? Oh
My god, it's the real country of Japan
Me when I go to Japan and there's not subtitles everywhere
I
Go men are sorry. I didn't want you
Yeah, I love anime
So good job Japanese girl better learn English
Oh fun service, we're named three minutes in
I don't know it was going there
Oh my god, it's AC
That's me kawaii ask me if I'm dubbing an anime
Oh my god vealer made cafe when I
Think I'd unironically love to develop a game about a made cafe
And then you want to have like the biggest made cafe that ever did
Is our little sister as well. Oh shit. Oh
My god, is there a little sister as well? Oh
Oh the girl I found okay, hi shio-chan
No, they've been represented by fucking sweet one sizes one smaller and one's bigger
They're having bath time together
He's got more buoyancy
Our comedies principle fuck I wouldn't even understand
My model react do you want me to turn it off I can turn off for the model reaction if you want
No, she's got me mouth fine
RGB strong in my balls
My retinas
Look over six minutes in and we're getting married
Kokoro means heart in Japanese because that one has to make you song I listen to
Vealer moderate real spot you
You
We're taking down the high table real and true capitalism's the root of all problems real and true
Best anime ever ten out ten ten out ten don't care what happens next ten out ten
Oh, I love her hair as well. Are we bunches are so cute
I
Doki Doki's heartbeat
Gumbar a your best
I
Love when like one person says a whole ton of words and the response is
I know hi means yes, and it's quite interchangeable with a lot of senses structures and words and stuff, but just
ah
Not any
We can go to stacks for that channel, so is love.
Oops, I got a little sis at home.
I've already given my heart to recent.
I'm watching it on my iPad right now.
I'm watching it on my iPad right now, so is love.
She wants us to quit?
What's your problem?
I'm watching it on my iPad right now.
I'm watching it right now.
Wow.
I'm watching it on my iPad right now.
I'm watching it right now.
I think you smell it to be honest.
Okay, yeah, he knows what he's done.
Oh, you've done it now.
Oh, we've saved him.
Oh, he's got PTSD.
Aw, what such a shame.
I can't sleep.
Cougars are dangerous animals.
Oh, what the second?
Oh, more?
Oh, we've got a motivational factor.
Hmm.
Mushy-mushy.
Oh, there's a normal person in this anime.
Don't worry, it gets a lot worse than this.
Oh.
Hmm.
What this?
How can I keep up?
Nope.
Oh, our paths are crossing, but not the good canes.
Ah.
Yeah, I'm a bit too late.
Hmm.
Uh.
Did she do it?
I should do it?
Monko? Well, fucking rival already ended. Hold on, let me do it.
Oh my gosh, she keeps saying the n-word.
Okay, okay, okay, go next, go next.
I'm ready when you are.
Okay, are we all ready for the next episode already? Yes.
I love that she's hooked, you ready? Okay, always on go.
Three, two, one, go.
Also, the last scene being a crowbar, freaking splat.
The next anime we were- I really like that. Like, is it hook? I think it's called hook in a song.
The next anime we were going to watch was Vibe something I was the plan.
Is the next anime in English? I have no idea. I don't know if it's got a dub or a sub.
I thought all the anime ended up with a dub or a sub, but I was mistaken.
Vibe, aye.
Shawnee, Riplin. They can't dub 400 anime every year.
That's it, I'm going to Japan to learn Japanese and then I'll dub everyone.
And then when I need to play the yandere, you disgust me.
But it's just my Scottish accent. You disgust me. You're absolutely filthy.
You don't touch me. You think you stand a chance when I have you? When I have you?
Okay, okay, okay, what happened? What happened?
She's certainly got the murder eyes on.
Oh, to be murdered at 8 minutes past 9 at night.
Can't be friends with the Scottish accent.
The dread's setting in.
Oh no, she's having a panic attack.
And she can't get out.
She's been hurt.
She's been haunted?
Uh oh.
You are disgusting.
As if she knows the location of the maid cafe.
Hen. I thought it was a girl.
Hen. He.
She's quick with it.
When the Elden Ring lightens this.
Sorry for dirtying your sofa.
Oh, well, she's not giving up where she's living either.
Tai Yu means fun. She did a bad man. She already ghosted.
She's got quite the color scheme, pink, blue, green, red, white, a little bit of brown.
Oh my god, we're in the sea.
Hmm.
Stop. I'm so immature. I'm so immature.
I'm so immature.
And what you love will turn to ashes. Hey, what's so bad about ink?
What? She's happy to be jealous?
What?
Happy sugar license. She said it, she said the phrase.
Is he about to find her?
Why are you sniffing the paper girl? She's about to go home to an empty apartment.
She's about to lose it. No doubt in my mind she's about to lose it.
She has a lovely long hair.
I don't doubt it. I actually don't doubt her words.
Oh no.
Senor.
Oh my god.
That moment she knew. She.
Yes.
Yeah, it's abuse of parents.
Monka.
This anime was going to be, it's not what I expected.
What my fridge sees at 3am?
Oh no.
She's too scared to move.
You thought happy sugar life was going to be a cute story?
Kindle, yeah, I mean the title was very misleading.
So she horny because she can't get it, don't you?
That'll pass though.
Oh, I almost got to see you, see?
Uh, who did we get grabbed by?
No.
Oh no.
No, I don't like this.
Uh-huh.
Dobby beef, poby beef, poby beef in Japan, sorry.
What the hell is that confession?
That was so everywhere, sorry.
The milk traumatized them so much, it became a loliko.
You'll enter.
Monka.
I don't like that.
And there are no churches.
Hmm.
I said it was worse, she just doesn't drew.
Is it actually?
Oh my god.
Uh.
Cold happy sugar life, by the way.
Yakutsa?
Uh, Yakutsa question mark.
Dobby Vivon, please.
Monka, Monka, Monka.
Wait, she went.
Her mom used to get hit in front of her and she saw all of it.
Her mom protected her through it all.
Is Okasa dead?
Bruh, don't end the episode there, what the fuck?
We're bombing into four, oh my god.
So Okasa used to get absolutely walloped right in front of her.
Hold on, go next, sorry.
We'll take a pause after this one, promise, but oh my god, we need to go next.
We need to go next, right.
We're on episode four, happy sugar life.
Okay, you ready?
Three, two, one, go.
And then I promise we'll take a break after this one, we'll get some food, we'll get some drinks.
Bruh, I need to know.
You're not ready for the family war?
So mom used to get walloped and she can't handle the sight of blood.
Did she used to get hit?
And then her mom's freaking ghost is looking after her.
Does the mom understand that the yandere is probably her best safety bit?
Oh shit!
What?
Can she catch a wee break?
Her mom's spirit is gaging her.
Her mom protected her.
Her mom's spirit, I will never forgive you.
You let go of my hand.
What?
She's a baby, this is no fair.
Oh my god.
The urge to skip the opening?
I know, just so we can learn.
I'll leave it, I'll appreciate it for what it's worth.
I actually quite like this, it's pretty good.
The opening is such a contrast.
Don't pillar by the hair.
Oh fuck.
Oh my god.
He's doing the knee thing.
Oh she didn't kill, okay, just meme.
Oh my god.
Oh, and the plot second is now he knows that we have Shio-chan.
Oh yeah.
She's not feeling well.
Smells like Sato-chan and oddly like iron.
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, we're together again, that's a good part.
But that certainly ramped things up in the end.
Oh.
Our aunt was a Yandere and told her the ways.
I don't think I've ever seen a plot like that before.
Yandere runs in the blood.
Is she gonna lulker the fucking?
I don't know some shitty aftercare.
Yandere runs in the family.
Tomahawk.
I tried miso soup from a Japanese takeaway, it was bogan.
Itadakimasu.
Oishii desu.
Yup.
Oh, that's a fiver.
That's a fiver.
Oh.
Locks her in.
That was a fire.
Can he lock some boots even?
Oh, she said it!
That's like the third time now, we are winning.
Is she even happy?
I don't think she was happy.
We've got bank.
Oh, Senpai. I forgot Senpai was technically on her side.
I should go after him? What the fuck?
That's not tickling, that's not tickling, I don't know about you, but that doesn't look like a tickle to me.
Ain't no pickle being tickled in there.
Oh, Senpai is scared of us.
Senpai is kohai.
Oh, you better not be causing us bother.
Can he speak to the ant?
Is the ant the trash?
Oh wait, it's clicking.
Was the trash her ant?
So she could live together with Saito because she couldn't get.
Oh no.
The plot tickled.
I know we need to take a break after this one.
Can we get another show? I'm done for another show scene in the alleyway, that's the long saying in the street.
You all hate to take a break, I'll make the quickest, never make taking a quicker break.
She took both their eyes.
You know, when you have optics or eyeballs.
I had to sew something there.
Seifu.
Morning.
Yandere's gonna have something they value.
Watashi wa the dangeru.
Yumi means dream.
Yumi plus.
He's obsessed now though, because he got to see her.
He's losing it.
He's drilling.
Imagine going to see your son's room and see that on the wall.
What in the Emmy is your name on YouTube and profile picture?
I've actually seen that anime.
I don't care what anyone says it was a good anime.
Shoot me.
I don't feel privacy.
When I was with my parents they didn't give a shit what I was doing.
What anime?
It's like my little sister can't be this cute or something.
They both got blonde hair.
And she's like into Auroge.
She's not happy.
She's only right.
She's only happy when she shows up, but she's not actually happy.
Really?
Ero manga sensei is 12 episodes 2.
Whoa!
I look away for one second and read the first subtitle.
What?
Am I going mental?
I look away for one second and the subtitle goes,
oh my tits will go back to normal.
Alright then.
I missed the first part too.
Oh my god!
She's an architect!
I can't believe it.
Same.
It's all in the seats.
All.
Don't you start and start and start?
She washes.
Is it an apartment already, Felix?
Okay, that makes sense.
Whoa!
1.2 million yen.
Is it, I think if you think...
$12,000 or something?
Oh, we know the yen and the dollar completely changed
I wonder.
She really is being haunted.
What the fuck?
She's drawing the damn thing, Snow!
Walk, you know.
I'll open up five, but we're going to take a quick break
and grab some food and snacks.
Oh my god, this anime is bizarre.
It's Byzantine Empire.
It's $8,000.
I mean, she's working hard.
I heard in Japan how you call it.
It's different.
Don't read this out loud!
Oh my god.
There's a post-credits scene.
I hate when animes do that.
Just fucking...
Post-credits scene.
Okay, hold on.
Sorry, we're back on episode 4.
I hate when animes do the fucking credits
and then a post-credits scene.
Fuck up!
Where the credits last!
Right, I am on the credits
where it's the two rings out of a pot that's broken.
There are a lot of post-credits scenes.
Nope, that's it.
You're getting put in the bin.
Any anime that does that is getting put in the bin.
In the bin.
You're out there.
Let me skipity-boo the intro
and let me skipity-boo the outro
and just watch the thing.
Controversial take.
Right.
Is everyone on the rings in the jar in episode 4?
Everyone on the rings in the jar.
Rings in the jar.
Oh yeah.
She hates happy to realize.
Okay.
Right.
Rings in the jar.
Broken.
Episode 4.
Credits scene.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Go.
What piano plan?
Oh.
Kawaii Disney piano plan.
We're at the cafe.
Right.
I promise I won't skip the next one.
Se aijou.
Blinding light.
Pants.
Hello?
Oh no.
Another one.
No.
Those who violate love must pay the price.
Such a sin can only be atoned for with punishment.
The taste of crime and the taste of punishment.
Episode 5.
Oh my god.
Can we catch a break?
I'm going to get a cola.
I'm going to make some food.
I'll be about 4 minutes.
Okay.
This is the first movie I have a close credit scene.
Probably.
But I'm not going to skip it anymore.
I'm going to watch it inner tyrity.
Okay.
You can have a whole 5 minutes.
Ah, mmh.
What is this?
Okay, how about four minutes? Okay, I'll be as fast as I can, okay?
Everyone make sure you stretch, make sure you get hydration while that does. I'm
going to get a colo, okay? The four-minute union allocated break, real and true.
And you making your way to the break room also counts as you've been on break, okay?
Right, burpee!
you
are we ready for some yandere time?
I've got a big, a few sandwich. I've got red onion, cheese, cucumber, carrot, corn,
tuna, and kippy mayo on a sandwich, on a sanger.
Bye-bye, 6am in the morning.
Hey, okay. Successfully rescheduled with Katarina. I will be on her channel at
a later date. Thank you so much. And again, if you- sorry, this is just straight up communication.
Okay, right. Successfully rescheduled.
All right. Oh yeah, kappa. That sounds awful. Wait, you don't like my sandwich?
It's got all the veggies and protein and everything. Oh, it's not really got protein,
unless you count the tuna. Oh, behind the scenes communication, yes. Are you guys ready to go again?
Sorry, I'm addicted. I didn't expect that. Someone on Marshmallow whenever I go says
iya neka. Oh, are you fucking serious? Means isn't it good, but it sounds like easy n. For
fuck's sake. Sorry, I didn't read the rest of the message. Are you fucking serious?
Rape line. Don't- don't do that. I don't read past the first word until it's too late. For
fuck's sake. Right, I said Japanese. Nihongo desu. Daijoubu. Daijoubu. Nihongo desu.
Stop. I can't believe I- right, anyway.
Hi, mommie. I think you got sidetracked and accidentally skipped my question. It was the
one that started with an apology for the dupe question. Oh shit, didn't I even finish it?
All right, sorry, let me try again. Hey, mommie. Sorry for the dupe question. Seeing how you get
when you're in subspace and the mention of how it feels, I had a blue side idea. You have-
I send you some stuff, like the pop stuff, and read through them on stream. I kind of think it
would be interesting to see if we can get you to ink without touching. Oh no, I can't- I don't have
that ability. I- I can't do that. I don't know how some people can do hands-free, but it's just not
an ability of mine. Clip. Stop. Does your sandwich need more protein? Real unsure.
Honestly, it doesn't sound as close to some of the other words. Very difficult. It's- I don't
have that at me for it. Scale issue? You know what? One fucking two. You should ink yourself now.
Right, are you ready to go? Are we ready to go again? Um, are we ready to go? A little- a
little cheeky three two one. God, sorry. I must forget. I need to space after the five.
A little cheeky three two one. Okay. Right, episode five. Happy sugar life. In three, two, one, go.
Ooh, speaking of food, it's a cherry tomato. Yee-haw, it's a tomato, y'all.
I've got cola as well.
Do you need more communication skills? Absolutely.
Oh my god, that's so ominous. Oh my god, it's
Coneology from Jen to Vila. Sorry. Right, I'm about to stuff my face whilst we watch this,
so give me a moment to really bite down on this.
Fucking crunchy.
I love the cutin' funny.
This is a shit sandwich. This is what this is.
What? Crunchy like the sock, honestly.
How do you make this sandwich, it's shit.
Is it bad yet?
Mm, mm, mm, mm, mm. If I mixed it together with the mayonnaise, it would have came out better,
but I didn't have time because I didn't want to leave you waiting too long.
So I literally just slapped everything on in between two pieces of bread.
I mean, that's what a sandwich is anyway, but...
I did this. Who's the culprit of these crimes, honestly?
I actually got the anxiety.
What?
I'm gonna... please open your mouth to accept my burp.
I'm sorry, that was rather disgusting, sorry. Sometimes I'm a little too sad.
Oh, fuck.
Possession alert. I like her outfit. Sending that one to the concept artist.
Here's a laugh in the world. Violently laughin' in your face after burpin' in her.
Oh, fuck.
Mm-hmm.
Shit.
Mm. I'm not yandere, are you?
She was just an ashtray. Smoking culture's pretty big in Japan.
How was I made? Fuckin' spare me egg? What kind of question was that?
Mm-hmm.
Ooh!
Oh
You're in a love confession
Hmm
Underwear hardly even or we a piss
She wants to replace me
You
Why are you digging in
No, no, I won't no, I don't think I will goodbye
Oh
What
What the fuck the fanservice is off the rails, what did she do that to make her be quiet?
Whoa
I
Got my sandwich locked into my hands and I ain't taking a bait
Don't tell me they're Lebanese
She's
Oh
Here come
This is such a good anime I find finish eating
You
You go into the room
I thought she was wearing a meter is the door
You
Oh
Okay, I finished my time when it only took me like half an hour to eat it. Oh
Is that why she's used to not going outside like she doesn't question it because her mum already like
Trained her if you will that outside is bad. That's why she doesn't question it
You
Oh, okay, okay, okay
Stop please use a different word
I know it's called sweet and sugar and what's the opposite of sugar bitterness, but come on. I'm too immature for this shit
Anime girl randomly comes out with the n word every episode
It's solely I go for that is salty salty this
You
Well, she's brief to ask the question
Oh
The vain punishment
I like literally sees her as an angel
He's going for the self report
Yeah
Oh
You
A strange exchange of affairs
Oh
She had feelings for um, okay, that's why she's pissed because obviously she the angel
How is the mum not hearing any of this get off me stop touching me
Even though you're hot
Is she old enough to even comprehend
Going
Whoa, this is bizarre
You
Can best is an
Okay
I was literally I'm like that's what she's I thought she's gonna be like yeah, I shanked them in the eyeballs
Oh my god
Also, I can't two books literally
It shouldn't bother you people like that then they aren't worth mentioning real
I thought she was going to confess the murders. I'm like, why would you tell her the that's gonna freak her out?
Of course, she's not gonna like this
Dice
You
Okay, that was a bit kawaii names, okay, I'll give you that one. I'll give you that one happy sugar life. That was a kawaii nisi
Oh
I didn't expect the physics
I didn't expect the physics to jump on it
I've got tears in my eyes
It was a weirded tear jumped on it
Oh
Okay, sorry the plot the plot
Crying
I'm okay. Yeah, we'll watch the creators. Oh, oh my god, the weirded tear jumped on it
Oh
I need a bite once we've watched the post-credits. I'm gonna go back to that scene because I need
Sorry
Oh my god
Oh
Oh my god, I'm so much tears coming from me
Oh my god, that wasn't even that funny. It wasn't even comedic. Okay, right post-credits scene. Let's go
Okay, oh my god a book out in a sweat
Okay, they're gonna team up right where was that scene
I didn't even know what happened. Where was it?
Right. I love you more even more than family. You're warmer and happier than my family
So this was the cute scene and I was like, oh, it's kawaii, you know
I don't even know if it was that funny
No, I wasn't that funny
I think just because I didn't expect it. It's like
It's just it was not that funny at all. Oh my god, right episode six. That was not that funny
I just I didn't expect a random tear to drop on her face. Oh
That was a good laugh. Oh wait, holy moly
It's funny. You have the strangest sense of humor in the
Oh
Oh, I just I didn't expect it and it was really funny. Okay
Oh, it's fine. I'm fine. Everything's fine. It's a yandere enemy not a comedy calm down women
Oh
Ha
Right, no, it's fine. I wasn't that funny
Okay, it's a wrong good everyone ready for episode six of happy sweet life
Let's hope there's no more tears falling on people's faces. Okay, because that was at least she's cry laughing this time not just crying
Oh
So I think that's the first time I've ever had a laugh and fit
Streaming it doesn't happen normally, but I never expected that's what happened
Strongly chuckles honestly, right? I'll do my countdown on go we go. Okay
Uh three two one go
Okay
How is the pierced and gone wrong I was healing his fine
I'm not having much problem
It's attached itself back on which is what I thought it would do. So it's all good
We know how to make you laugh now when you make you cry
Okay
Okay, so
I don't mean to be that person like I have a weird sense of humor. Okay
But if it's something evolving physics
And I don't expect it. It makes me laugh my ass off. There's this dumb ass meme, right?
Of uh receipt that was in a trolley, right?
It flies out of the trolley and someone plays the Harry Potter music as I do
And it's just the receipt
It's just the receipt flying out of a trolley
Okay, it's not even uh need to find it. Sorry. I think I'm in a giggly mood today
Hold on. Let me see if I can find the meme in between the credits
Harry Potter receipt and a trolley
I try to find it
No, what the fuck where is it? I don't know a receipt
I received flying out of a trolley
I can't find it hold on
No, it's not
I'll find it after this team. It's like a receipt flying out of a trolley. Oh, is that a car? Maybe
Uh, maybe it's a car because it's an american meme
Out of a car
Your laughter makes this sound so funny. It's not even mildly as humorous as I'm making it
To be I can't find it. Oh my god. Right. It's this trolley and there's a receipt and then someone played
Do-do-do-do-do-do over it. Okay, right enemy team enemy team. Sorry. I get a little full shrunk of them
Okay, back to that meme
I think I'm giving myself a headache laughing at that. Oh my god. I've lost some liquids having a giggle at that
hydration chair
Oh
Lock in let's lock in gamers. Sorry. Let's lock in weeps because we're certified weeps today
She wanted a word
Terms and conditions
Receipt car funny music my came to humorous
Have a harry potter in the magical lawn why not?
Mum will explain. Oh cause uh
Dice to keep us
I
Not I was about to perish
It was nice knowing you buddy
All right, okay, my spider senses were correct is the arm
Or it was the arm
You
Based movie in aslano based anime in aslano
He's gonna lure him into the apartment and kill him shortly. Well, he in danger all the
You
This is only enough room for one little icon in the stand wasn't
And
Wait are they looting her
Wait am I gonna see something really dumb right now is she doing stuff with her?
Or is she just like in love with her? I thought she was just in love with her
Hold on a minute. Have I missed a massive plot hole here?
Oh
The best anime's avatar the last bit of ended got it
I assume nothing else has happened because we haven't seen it. That's what I'm assuming as well
You
Mm-hmm
It doesn't change the fact that she kidnapped a wean and is in love with her. Yeah
Normally you root for the main character
I'm a bit biased the she's probably safest in the hands of the yandere question mark
Num maybe the brother
I don't know
Morally this anime is rather gray
I don't think she's safe for the cycle killer true true
Bum bum
I
So that's your safe for anyone actually like a magnet for bad stuff
Safe is to sleep under the bed when you've gotten abusive parent
You
Oh, I passed out because he's starting
I'm rooting for the good guys on the show the cops I'm rooting for shio and no one else
I have to Gimli relax. I think
And now she is feeding him architect bruise can't stop waiting with this one
So
It's sketchy
Shoko is the only normal person here people are biased because of the
Because Yuri fans need nourishment
What's the most common anime like tradition type a shounen a yuri anime
I don't know
Love a yender oh
This is so sad this anime
Is this
You
But she popped her clothes
Wait, I assume this is platonically right this isn't like some Osaka
Wait Osaka for police in the town
This is getting weirder. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is like neutral, right? This is neutral, right?
Okay, no alabama here. Okay. It was just a
Okay, okay. Okay. Just checking like you never be too sure of these enemies
Okay
What is I
You
No
Row he took all his fingernails
Oh my god
You
And the tea
Brothers I'm so sad
You
By the strong he has your toe non-existent gone to the either
Wait, so then they call so he only looks for shio
Is that because he knows that oh that mother dearest has popped her clogs
If it was me during the night, I wouldn't have a father anymore
Yay alcohol poisoning has its pros. Oh my god, he's happy. Okay
Yay alcohol liver carousels
Hey
What
No, no, no, no, no, no, then he then he come back to the present
Go back. I want to see the rest of the memories pause go back
Go back to the rest of the memories right now. I want to see the plot
So the mom's still alive
So he's too late for the mum the mum broke main broke, but she hasn't
Yeah, baby, that's what I've been waiting for
You
Okay, we're having a little girls day out. Yay some positivity for the end of this episode
Good girls fashion nail polish discussing boys taking pictures for instagram
You
Meet me
Face the music
You
I mean shouldn't feel threatened so that's the good news, right?
Hi riflin why are you crying the first thing you say is hi cry
I'm enjoying it. I had a laugh and fit. I've been shocked. I've had a few gasps
I don't know why the timer is freaking broken. I'll fix it next time you do a watcher on your breath
Not the east cubes shivering
Some like once in a while
Reasons to cry and I need creative I miss something
I mean she's telling it how it is
You definitely don't get involved or you're gonna end up with a eyeball
Oh
Oh, are you sure
Ah
Oh
Is she gonna say that she's going to win
Is she actually gonna tell her she can tell feathers
Sorry my throat just croaked if you heard that when I gasped uh
Uh
It's happening
Meh meh it's happening. Okay. What's the posting credit now?
This isn't gonna end well
Now I don't want to say anything too controversial, but I've noticed in the opening there are three bags
And one two bags have pink on them and one has blue
Implying
Potentially three deaths
By the chanderi now. I've already got confirmation or looks like it's confirmation that one pink bag was anti
So there's room for the blonde guy in the blue bag and then there's one more chick that's going down
And I'm getting nervous. Okay. I'm getting nervous
I'm getting sweaty. I'm getting shaky. I'm I'm not sure how this is gonna go
The best part is episode nine. So we're officially halfway through this anime officially
You think the bags are the owners I could be wrong I could be wrong. This is just my shitty theory
I
Have no idea how this is gonna end and getting kind of puzzled every time like every time a new episode comes
Why do I feel like averting my eyes is it friendship lust or is it no
What the sugar girl is made out of
I
wasn't much of a posting further
Barton my mess
We're on episode seven
As I said, uh, I'll go back in timestamp when we actually start the episode versus me yapping
Who goes there identify yourself? Um
So you're planning to do this monthly one anime a month
So I can officially say I'm a weeb and no one can say that I'm not a weeb
Okay
10 out of 10
I think I I think I found the receipt video
I put it in marshmallow
If I projectile vomit, then you know, you found the right video because
I
Okay, I've got I've got all my giggling out my system clearly link is it?
Oh, sorry. That was very rude of me. Of course. I should link it. Sorry
So I had a laughing fit over this video. It is the right video, but I think um
I'm all giggled out after my big laughing fit. I have I have no more giggles on the tank at the moment
I don't know why it tickled me pink when I thought
I
It's just a goofy
Thank you for
That laugh is absolutely durable. You're on pain meds or something else aren't you? No, I'm raw dog in life right now
I
I strongly when I listen to your all audios and you
Firework before I do I imagine smashing you harder while you're scoring just what you should know. Well
That's the rather honest marshmallow, isn't it?
Right are we ready and steady
for
the
10 views, how do you
How did you find that?
Yeah, actually does have 10 views. Wait a minute. All those views are ours
Yeah, this is when I just
Strongly, I love you, but that was not funny. Well, I gave me a laughing fit when I saw it for the first time
Get right. All right
ready for episode seven happy sugar death life
And t-minus three two one go
Over getting lower the girl's parents passed away when she was young
Oh
My humor is
And it just happens to be
The one she can't even have her own family said
Oh
That's why she perished her
MC was a slag
You
The contrast of the intro is insane. I love it
It's just this guy's theory
And I think he's on the right. That's what my guesstimate would be from the information
I've gathered and
Simultaneously probably accidentally forgotten a few things
Come out with a new bag for him
It came to him in a dream, but that's just the theory a game theory
I don't think there was an ant. Oh
No, I want to say the ant taught her about the yandere stuff because the ant always shows up and she's like oh
You're injured again. You're hurt again
But she was probably running away in yandere stuff, you know
Didn't this be a film theory, but that's just a theory an anime theory
Kawaii
Mommy's so bright. Yes, they're the brighter scenes. I'm fucking gallowing
We should watch made in abyss for the contrast thingy. Well, it's like constantly white black white black white black
Since the right and suggest he's pretty much correct by his mouth
It seems likely I second made in abyss. It's quite good though. It's also some eyebrow reason
The show gives omori though. Ain't that that one video game?
Just with how people have distorted reality
You
We're getting low for her as well
Made in abyss has two seasons in the bin right now has that one season 12 episodes and then I'm satisfied that there's no filler episodes
I'm here for the plot I want to know what's up
Is that my oh my pc's taken off well, it was nice knowing you
That has zero filler so maybe a weaver lawn a weaver thorn
You
Be if I had a Kawaii Disney voice it'd be over for you bitches
Hontoni
Kawaii
Like if I had a Kawaii Disney voice it'd be over
It is a different charm to your voice
Kokon Kokute
He already took you to handle
Animates have cliffhander endings to make you read the manga
I actually find it really cool how a manga gets uh
Uh no
Uh
Manko
Oh
How do we get around this oh my god, well, why is it in that position?
What
Uh
Is he
Is he hands free and right now
I
Think he's hands free and right now
You
Oh my god, he's like
Bro
You get nervous
What
Uh
Is the game up
No, I'm getting tea so badly by this anime
I
What
You
Oh what
Um
Oh
What
I'm sorry, I'm just playing Smithy
You
Definitely different apartment
And the notes
You
What sorry, I'm I got nothing to say
Hey
Is she shitting in there are you shitting in there?
Oh, is that where she logs her her guests is this the good cave
The goon room
Uh
I see the goon cave, okay, real unsure
Me when a tear drops on an anime girl's face
Whoa
You
What
She wants a boy cherry real untrue really
She's gonna milk him she's gonna perm in the gun cave
Is she a massacre
Whoa
Okay, yeah, okay, she likes this
I'd I'd fold like a lawn chair. I saw I'm saying I'd be tentin
You caught me. I'm folding like a lawn chair
Oh
My hands are on my head
Fuck she's fucking going on her as well
Oh
Oh, he wants it he wants the gunning cave
Stop stop picking on everyone
She's gonna put you in the gunning cave don't do it
Oh
No, leave her at the gunning cave
And is there a true chef
You
At strony's future the ginky
She's scared
Oh
Oh no
She sees through the lies
You
Just
When he's saying no means goodbye forever
Those are the same block but
You
You'll switch your route brother wit lush in this anime
Like the scenes are so cute when they're together, but like every other scene is like
It just was a random family to terrorist well, they seems like it to me
Maybe that's what the three bags where there's three
Oh
Yeah, my next case would be that she just killed her relived in the apartment. Yeah
Back to square one for who she perished. Yeah
This is
Very
I don't know what I was getting
So obviously I looked up. I was like, oh, what's the 12th part or anime that's like highly rated
And all I got told about this one was yandere. That's it. That's all I got told yandere
but like this is
This is the Byzantine empire because of how bizarre everything is going on
um
That assumes there's security cameras, no now the same the same england
There's cctv everywhere and the crime rate solving cases numbers are like rubbish
I don't think storing dead bodies in your own apartment is a good idea
After admit the goon cave is hilarious though for the aunt as much as the aunt is absolutely mental
The goon cave is hilarious. I don't care what anyone says
Oh, there's a bit of a smell emanating from this room. Can we check it out? Oh, I don't think that's a good idea
Oh, no, don't do that. And then they go in they start like hacking and wheezing the
The smell of ink is too thick in the middle. Like, sorry, that's funny. I can fix her
Oh the real post-credit scene this time
No, she's tracking it up, but she's not making much progress
Unless you spent all night doing it
Oh
You'll you still you
Hmm
What
You
Is this how she got the apartment
It is episode eight apartment life and went away
Oh
Sorry, I'm sucked in I'm I've got the good suck. Sorry. This is such a good
Anime, I don't care why no one says I'm
Sucked in are you I are you okay if I go
Really quickly for a tinkle because I didn't think I want to sit more right there. Okay. I'll just be a moment
I literally won the toilet is right there. Okay. The toilet's right there. Give me one second to tinkle
You
We want to put there for from 97 is that long or are you teasing?
Be honest. Are you teasing?
Hey
Mommy's gone. I was just
I think I did give myself a a mild headache. I don't really feel it when I sit still
Laughed so hard at teardrop
On someone's face that I give myself a headache. All right, you ready to go next because
Getting into it. Yeah, sorry if you're giving ready. Did you wash your hands? Nope
I want to maximize my time with the refunds. I did not wash my hands
Ready three two one go
Okay, we're starting straight in the intro this time
I
Want me to lick your hands clean are you sure you want that?
Uh
Singular lamo even episode nine is a dizzy. Well, we're on episode eight
Yeah, we're on episode eight
Wait, are we on eight or nine?
Have I replayed the same one by accident?
Hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, sorry
Oh
You
Yeah, those three trash bags we better find out why there's three
So we're not getting to see
You
Yeah, flash but yeah, we're not getting to see the POV of the person
This is the unique way you tell stories
Oh
You
She's an own own niece son on it
She's viola material real and true
Thanks
You
It's shelf in a hobby
We're gonna be a past thing
For some people
You can make it into
Only if it's a man's money it becomes a hobby
Hmm
Well, maybe if the businesses and the charge of ridiculous fee on top you need to access the ball then counterfeit some
You
Just get sticking them out
Where am I
You
You have 10 for half moment
Oh, let's get face real
And then why did she perish him
You
Stay tuned
Because I want to see you come see
You
I didn't know what her expression meant
Oh
Hey
You
Wow, this is such a bizarre story tone
I'm too low IQ. I need it. I need them to spell out to me
It's up with her face. I've never seen her look so happy and satisfied
Disgusting disgusting disgusting disgusting disgusting. That's not who she is
What is this feeling
Oh, I see I
Like how she was incomplete
I like her when she's crying
That she's not satisfied
That's why she's in the way
Oh
I surely regret it. I regret I couldn't see your face in the end
You
Whoa, and now we know who is in the bag
I
Thought his head was gonna be there
That's bag number one
That might be the blue bag
You
Blinded crazy
You're angel getting away is it gonna give up the hunt
Oh
No, I'm scared by a woman
Oh he ain't fix
He ain't sick
So a bit being normal me when women
Me when women
He's becoming haggphobic truly a worse fate than death
Oh
I don't know
She rubbing it in his face
You
Oh
Oh my god
You
Her sock
No, not the same training
No
No the same training the same play
No way the origin of the crusty sock
No
You
Level it's over for him she rolled on that 20 just like that
Hey for real mommy this feels so similar to something else whatever it picks on you a party
You
Oh my god, are they gonna kiss
I'm slowly brother and sister
Oh my god, she's in subspace now we got her boys wrap it up
Well somebody please save shield
So
Just remember she left her that sock in case you need to use it on them real and true
If the sock didn't work in the panties we're coming off next
Should go cannot be saved it's over
I don't know about them but I think we should
I'll do the s effects don't worry
Mmm
Tena tena s effects
She's asking him to go to brazil clearly
You
You're gonna start drilling again in the middle of the cafe
Is an acp
You
The manipulation
Oh
Is it the is it the sensei
Is the sensei go for it again. Oh, oh, oh wait. No, no, no, that's the blonde one given him a false tip
That's what really said dance puppet dance
Pilling all of that go to risen is she gonna hurt me? It's like a car crash. I know I shouldn't look at the same time
Make them up and get some tips from you. So no post credit
Are you skipping ahead for me? Is there actually no post credit?
There isn't okay. We skip into nine
We
When I have to go back through this I'll be like, oh, can I stop yapping and actually start the dam on me?
It should be time for a break now. What should we do?
Well, I go get crispies. I don't know what to do for the break
However, I go get some crispy
I
Don't say this one out loud either, but it means run away, but it sounds like the other thing
Nigh run, I off I skipped out something
That laugh was adorable
How bad was the laugh? I don't know if I'll be able to time it. I have no idea what the timestamp of the laugh was
All right, I'm gonna very quickly grab some quickies, okay
Because I bought it's called honey soy
flavored crisp like chicken honey soy
Hey, I'll just be a minute because it's just in the kitchen. Okay one minute
You
How can you pick I was I was on Melissa. I wasn't even six the same girl gone for that time
At two hours 33 minutes is when I had a laughing fit
Go on then two hours
Is it two hours 32?
Oh no, oh, it's not displaying correctly
Ah
It's because the stream isn't finished the time is like minus three hours 41 or whatever, but I can't do it backwards
I ain't smart enough for that
You're going for a whole 10 seconds
Life without strong is so
bitter
Okay, are we ready for part nine? We're about to finish actually
What nine ten eleven twelve? Yeah, we're literally about to finish
All right, you ready? Okay
On go three two one go
Or literally about to finish
I
Wanted this for only this moment. What the fuck happens in this episode
I've got quick be you want crispy first go
Ah
One two at one
Oh
I wouldn't just believe what the heck
You
I react to my laugh tomorrow when I deal
We'll react to my laugh at the end of the
When stroney is going everything is better
Plus
Oh
But it's a false clue
Yeah, try to lure them away
Oh
I mean he did hand over
I can't keep up
Everyone's getting interconnected in a spider web
Oh
His cyscon radar tells him that she's in town
That's just sad
Oh
Oh everyone's connected
What
Why should you remind it is she gonna confess
I
Think I'm just shagging the park
So then what's the mum lore why was the mum too far gone?
So
You
Okay, I finished my snackie no more munching
Oh
They're doing a doggy stay on the park get them
What oh let's just install them on the way out
Oh
What
Is she just an assault that every living day lights out of him
Kisses him and then insults him
What in the fendom is this
What in that degradation is this
You
Again a bit speechless at these stages I'm not really sure if there's anything I can commentate on it's just
Oh
Like it's so wholesome and she's literally talking about perishing someone a moment ago
La pizza silly
Yuri fanservice off the steels
Why is it the desserts in anime always look so scrumdilly umptious and ironically
I
Was tickling a bib I don't think I don't know what the animators are doing
That's twice. There's been tickling in this anime and twice. It's been a bib
Because nobody likes to watch she fits
No, it was me
You
Illegal
Oh god, I'll sign him. He's bright
I don't remember that one
You're just jealous that boobs to tickle. You don't want one going going to the naughty corner two and think about what you've just said to me
You
Okay, bye puts myself in the corner
This is still rather morally brave
I
This is how it really filled everyone in this show this show is certainly unique. I don't think I've ever consumed anything like this
I'm not sure how I feel about this
Yeah, this isn't morally great. This is fucked up. Honestly. I'm like
This is not she kidnapped the girl called multiple people in life. I caught what do you mean?
Oh
Shaitou
Oh shaitou
I'm fucking scared
All the police man came over for the shag. Oh, he's in the gun cave
Let's go clover
Eh
We have it
You
What
Uh
Why is she getting a song I don't like where this is going
I don't like where this is going
I
I'm getting real nervous
That my three back theory wasn't exactly wrong
You
When they use the word sayonara
I don't like this
She's walking away, okay
Okay, just leave the apartment
Uh
You
Oh
Whoa
Bro open up the next
110 right
She sent the picture silly
Mwah, okay. Are you ready?
Don't
Are you ready?
I'm ready. I'm I need to know I need to know
All right, three two one go
For this intro compared to the last episode
Wah
That was that was harsh
I
Don't even have like words to formulate about the situation. I'm like, how does this end?
If my back theory is correct, that's two bags out of three
The first one being the artist who owned the apartment
Two was the best friend that she never saw as the best friend. So what is three the brother?
You
More
Mm
Yeah
The third bag is you
Too many aces in this anime sorry, uh, yeah
You swap out a few of the aces and everyone starts with an s
Oh
Flashback
You
Is she gonna come across the body
She can get into the canned foods and she was hungry
You
Flashback
Oh
You
The whip
Mm-hmm
She goes I pretend I do not see seatbelt warning honestly
Oh
You
Oh my gosh, you got bad polar
Who will come for you the mat the dad
Her brother
And she goes outside one
And she gets kidnapped by the main character
You
Oh, I'm not I feel like I'm gonna be like green
Oh
What no, that's not
You
No
The fun
Really taking her
You
What she just dropped her
What
You
What she's lost it
She lost the plot
You
Dang she's the one
I did she draw so high up playing damn shirts like a monkey
You
She needs to get there because of her action
A little bit
So that's the thing kidnapped for just founder. Yeah
You
I'm speechless
No
You
There's a lot of things going wrong right now
It's all coming apart
You
Ah
Oh my god, she literally just you know perished someone
Which is a cat
You
This feels like the finale it does I know there's two more episodes, but oh my gosh
Shoko died for this real
You
I like the symbolism of the kraken because like yandere's always like crack
Yandere's love crack
The mango wasn't finished yet and he tried their best and
You
What does she believe on
I should I kneel
I
Will either future together
You already broke the yandere's are literally
I don't know if we can re-smelt the jar is like in the thing heat some sand up real quick
My eyes are kind of like that those eyes I have literal cullfish eyeballs what are you on about?
This is bizarre business king empire
Uh
She don't even give you a shit
Hey, I killed someone. Yeah, no. Yeah
Oh nice and casual what
You
Hey, I said the thing
Good song
You
Are you squiddin me right now
Mama would love us to even if we kill someone underscore tingle colon underscore head pat
a refund
Boy, please don't be starving folk in the name of my only in streams night video games
I don't think you need to starve anyone
Oh
I
Was creepy not gonna lie. I was rather
I'm on what the spruce thank you boy for the super chat
I assume there's an end in this
I get it there
Not time for me
After this
Who's created it we will kill heretics, you know, we demand you know, the ghosts are back shadow blocks in time
I
Know what to formulate about this on me. Yeah, I know there's two more episodes to go forget him
You
Studio blank more like studio
Maybe
What
And each other moment with you. Oh my god episode 11 up to come
Any episode 11 watchers?
Hold on hold on any episode 11 watchers of happy sugar life
It's literally two more episodes and then
We get to fully formulate and confirm that I'm a weeb
Surely one episode of anime one one anime makes me a weeb sure
Still a gamer though
Okay
All right two more to go. How does this anime end?
three two one go
Um
Wait is he the one that killed his dad
But nothing changed
What a broken jar is how to do
Is that different dive or muckle? Okay. I was just chasing in case he was secretly leaving
Can't believe liver school isn't perlucent
No
Oh
I feel like the thoughts gonna thicken real quick
Then the intro gets me every time it's just hydration check response
You
Need to make fun of someone's favorite anime to get the weeb fired
One shot one shot viewers be like I can't wait to watch another episode of filler
Did I do it right?
Surely there's filler episodes in one shot because how in earth do you get a thousand
See like episodes of an anime and it's not filler just pure filler
How many times have they done a beach episode
What's one shot? Oh one piece. Sorry. Sorry the one piece is real
Sorry the one piece is real
What sorry one shot is what I am okay 70 percent recap is the previous episode
One shot is a fantastic game
And you want a weeb card after naming one of the biggest enemies incorrectly. Yeah, sure why not
If one piece was one shot people wouldn't have waited 30 years. Yeah one shot one
One piece fans be like, oh, I can't wait for another season to drop and it takes another four years to produce
Fucking wrap up the series surely the story's ended right surely
Did you not remember about what I said about being publicly executed
I
Feel like if you're watching a one piece
You're just here for a good time and you're like, haha. Yeah, okay, you got me you got me 800 episodes then you got me
But he just cannot get a break from bdsm
You
Oh
You guys kidnapped me almost four heads the average roofling
You
He's gonna rip his finger nails out
Oh
Joink in fingernails
Does it happen in kagaguri as well she rips all her fingernails off in a bit and I'm like
Is this like a common yakuza thing or something?
I lost my fingernails because I even get to the yakuza
Sorry, that was the most pathetic sense. Like I've ever muttered in a very long time. My apologies
I
Let you choose I was losing my finger. No, no, you're thinking of assassin's food
Oh
Is it what you get after
Home in math it's inflicted both the team
You
She's recruiting her aunt
To the good in cave at once
Oh, that is very eager
Is we're in black she's serious she is the yandere in but
Come and say to Felix she says that look
You
Honestly that needs me to show you everywhere
Unrelenting forgiveness
You
The blink noise
Extra money
You
The meaty I believe
What was that oh you can't make that sound
You can't make that sound
What is that oh, you don't know
If I do it sounds like a bullseye
You
It's just my mouth
My mouth is open
And I push my my tongue to my teeth
As I guess I have a really white mouth
Pop up up up
Have a lot of spit unfortunately
That's just the mpp for for an order
You're a dirty adult take responsibility
You
Maybe
Oh
Huh
So good mac and cheese
That's creepy as is at least the anus supportive of her antics
Yes
Well, uh shuko won't be picking up the phone
You
Mm-hmm, they can't get home
Yes, hey driver in
You
She's scared she's like bro, fuck that
Step on the dead
Oh
We're gonna fake passports
You
A little chaining bells
Oh, no, he's about to meet the male fun. No
Oh
He's about to go into the gunning cave
Oh, no
Oh
Oh, wait, no, she doesn't answer unless you drop the key
No, he's going into the fucking game
No, she's gonna
Oh
I
Oh my god
Oh
The music actually did start playing
Did go and upgrade to come I think he broke his jar
You
I know it can be messed up something real untrue
Oh, whoa, hold on
I'll jump hold on a minute
You know the murder I can forgive and you know a lot of stuff is rather forgivable
Hmm
To the final episode, yeah
This is rather
I did not expect it to
Rather curious. Yes
Is there an ending scene?
Bad sister, how do you forgive the murder? Oh, I can forgive murder
Uh any ending scene on this one it doesn't look like there's an ending scene on this one
Shoko
Like if shoko got the balls to go for it or back off, but because she constantly played on the fence that makes it up
Murder I assume that's how you wanted me to say it
Just a wee bit of my thumb. All right. Well
The finale
Shawnee I'm starting to question your moral compass. You don't remember I used to want to perish many
Can you forget that part? Okay, right?
This is the finale
I don't know how much will happen
We're going to find out
Well 24 minutes and we're going to review this this anime how? Okay, ready?
three
two one go
The finale
Shouldn't deserve to get murdered
Say that probably not
You know you got the Japanese passport you can pop off any prefecture
You can bring the wee rubber duck obviously why not
Oh
Oh, oh no
Okay, but actually me though, you're playing there's still some thick stuff. He's dying
I
That's what I want you to sound like by the same I'm finished for you
Sorry, I can't answer the phone right now. I can't get shagged by a milk
Good to dare that's a succubus there
You
You're gonna get an artwork made of us is it gonna be the scene I think the foot scene has my vote
I like the foot scene the most like the black male kind of thing
My current vote is the foot scene. I don't know how you guys would feel. We'll discuss it at the end of this episode
But I think I'd prefer the black male foot scene. That's my favorite kind of thing so far
Taken to mummy's gun cave. Oh, maybe maybe
So it's seen our gun cave my personal preference would be foot black male versus gun cave
But don't let me influence you
Mm-hmm
Mm
True winable
How about the food scene picture and
Young black male audio
Uh
She's alive. No, she cannae be
No, she cannae be alive
No
They're a bit morbid. Okay
Oh
Oh my
We're gonna wait
Oh
You asking for a war
And what position is he in was his legs behind his back
All right, no, it's his hand. Sorry. It was the it was the render distance
Oh no, his legs what oh my god, he's hog tied
Oh
Oh no
You
Uh
Right fight the crossroads in a minute
You
Look at your chops in the lift
Oh
She doesn't really seem to care
You
Oh my god, it's all
Pin pal read hi pin pals
We're watching the very last episode. I'm so sorry. This is a terrible stream to read out into
Sorry pin pals
Apologize we're watching the finale of happy sugar life
We're literally 13 minutes off the end and I have no idea what's about to happen
But hi, I hope you guys had fun hoping we had fun too. I'll be redirecting into zero
Eh once we finish up we've decided we're getting an artwork after this anime because this is that turned me into a wee
yeast
I
Got weaved weave all over me so now no one can say that I'm not a weeb because I watch anime get right
He's gonna find out
I've
Been diagnosed with
Hi, my cameo she has the watch along we're finishing it right now
Is a certain a member stream today rip it's mercy back streaming today
Move the redirect into her
You
Her leg
Oh shivi's gonna go off I'll redirect into shivi
Oh my god, she has the calm syndrome
You
Oh for the ring
Oh
Yeah
You
You guys are in a burning building wrap it up or smoke inhalation gonna get y'all
Carbon dioxide is music
As a carbon monoxide and maybe monoxide
I
She poisoned the alcohol
Ah
You
What
Is this going the way I think it's going
Yeah
You
What
I don't know why you're playing the upbeat music
Uh
Huh
Oh
I ain't got too dense for this
Flashes of what what their life could have been
You
Yeah
Huh
Would anyone like to very quickly summarize the fucking synopsis real quick what the fuck I don't get it
So they commit sudoku together
But because the body was cushioned she gave up her body as the ultimate love
And she lost a part of her mind and now the weans also yandere but think the part of satoshi because they're all beginning with s at the same time
Yeah
Uh
So that will protect us her where a body she basically became mentally ill
Hmm
You know for a recommended anime a movie a movie wondering why we started with that one
Huh curious
I'm gonna go harass she be if she's doing a gorilla or not
What my message should be
Are you doing
Gorilla
D
Just plain hit man
Where did you find this on red? It was right a titan 12 episode animes and this was the very first one that was recommended
Um, well the next one was gonna be vivi the it's vivi good before I swap it out
All right, don't trust red it red it bros
Oh, no, are you guys okay? I don't know 50 mt. Thank you very much for the five gifted memberships
I mass
It's an e sanshi go go gifted memberships. That's right. We're weeps out here
Okay, you guys actually recommend vivi. Okay next month is vivi
Uh last time i'm gonna trust those kind of recommendations because
Yeah, that was um curious to say the least
Um
That was an anime that ending
And just about everything actually about that anime was rather curious. Yes
Uh, so what was the anime about? Uh, good question. Um
Yandere cheeky bit of lolly con
cheeky bit of just
Insanity really
um
Husky 3721 thank you for the 20 gifted memberships jesus. You guys like anime that much?
I fucking did a shit watch along with that one
Um
I also watched the stream
Uh, yes
That was very unique. I did not expect it to go that way like the the intro. I really like the intro
I like the sensei black male section
Uh, I like um
Thank you very much for the gifted membership. Yeah, dang
Donations to never listen to read it recommendation again, I think I'll let you guys recommend the anime that's really 12 episodes or less
Uh
Oh, yeah, there was also the grape on the guy by uh hags. That was very unique. I haven't seen that before. Um
Would you be willing to do a 24 episode anime? Uh, it would open up a lot of good recommendations. Uh,
possibly maybe with a
rating out of 10
like
I had I don't know if I can rate it until asleep on it
Like when when it was the whole like sensei black, but oh 10 out of 10 loved it. Oh, that's cute
I like kind of finding out more about the story. Um
It kind of feels like one of those empty endings where it's like
Oh people died but for what because basically
What
Ween got like
I don't know. I think I think I'd need to I need to nap on it to be able to accurately range it. I like the show
It was curious
I know you have to remember I don't watch too much concepts like that before she died for love
I mean, I guess. Yes. She event. She got her love in the end. That makes sense
Um, I also only watch
Only your first time, but visually had a lot of bad things come on between the past
and
Hairboy B-Bot she'll basically just becomes mentally ill and becomes like fat old and that's pretty much the ending
hit or miss
My recommendation is daily lives of high school boys. I thought it was funny
Violet Evergarden will we watch it together?
Did I really just miss the stream? I'll teeny tiny whiny bit
Um, it says she be's on hitman absolution right now. I don't know if that's what she was planning on doing
a cheeky
cheeky bit of
Um
Yeah, she never missed her
Uh
I'm just waiting she be is currently busy on discord. So I can't see it 12 episode. I don't mean 12 episodes
It's like my modus. Yes. I will fix the watch along tamer nice thing because I don't know why that broke
I feel like it was working the track
When I saw her face
Now I'm a believer
Uh
Cam on strongy give happy sugar life a fair shake
It had you invested from episode one just admit the rory con and I mean it's good
I'm becoming a weaver rory con. Yeah is a
Whoa, no stereo
stereo
Lollipop shrek 5 and 226 remember 100% would recommend angel beat every six episodes or more
She had a migraine and didn't stream. Hmm
Someone says she's gonna do gorilla
That sounds like the turtle
I'm not sure what to feel walking away from I'm sure I'll have a better opinion tomorrow. Thank you, brulee legend for the set
I said, we're just gonna watch ben tie together
She tweeted about
that but it was an oracle
Angel beats made me cry. I was a journey all right, but I have a good plot then
Okay, if you guys are recommending a
very then
I will I'm happy to do that next month and then we'll come up with the next like
We're only gonna do one anime watch a long pair of months like I'm not gonna like all of a sudden turn around and be like a anime expert
in actually
Bentay is better. Okay, let's do bentay
And
hearing you hum
Even a couple seconds of the song gave me PTSD flashback flashbacks never read
It's the only piece of me now ever consumed in the reading that terrified me
Wait, what did I hum?
What is that hum? Good. Good night, pun pun
This isn't a bad song
It's oh, yeah
I know that it's hard to do
It's a good song not particularly that
ever we've strung so
I would recommend personal faith being blood see it's very uh
It's very fully dubbed. I don't know. We're gonna find out next month when I have to talk about
Hey, strutty
Just to let you know there are animes that are 11 or 13 episodes as well to be sure to look up for those
I'll throw in quick recommendations. Uh, I know Hannah. It's a living ex as well
Uh, hey, strutty. Hi, Rachel. And I would also recommend you read
Read or die over a very important
Optional reading
It's somewhat like x-men mutant
Uh-oh, I know Hannah mentioned. Wait, what's wrong with I know Hannah?
It's been recommended
Hi, strutty. I love your dorky sense of humor. Your laugh sues my soul. Actually, wait, where is my laugh?
Where's my laugh? I want to hear it
I I had a laugh and fit on one of the episodes like an absolute baby. Oh god. How quick would it be in?
Oh, I have no idea where it would be
We'll be laughing, but
I
See everything the water streams five hours ago
And then it would be what three hours and 20 minutes
We'll try
Sorry the way it's displaying on my end isn't actually showing me
What the
Oh, I'm gonna have to just clip it and find out tomorrow
There's a 314
Oh
You're gonna hear myself twice don't panic
Okay, I'm about to have a laugh and fit in the voice chat. Don't worry. Don't panic
No, my youtube keeps bugging out they freaking update youtube so it's just one big buggy mess now
I thought she was going to confess the murders. I'm like, why would you tell her the
No, it's gonna freak her out. Of course. She's not gonna like this. Oh my god. It's me in the past. Hi past me
I'm waiting for the laugh. Come on
Okay, that was a bit kawaii news. Okay, I'll give you that one. I'll give you that one. Happy sugar life. That was a kawaii news team
Oh
Oh, no, it broke it broke dammit. Sorry my u-block is also a cap to books literally
It was laughing
Oh, I need it. But once we've watched the post-credits, I'm gonna go back to that scene because I need it
You laugh for like five minutes
Sorry
Oh my god
No
Okay, okay, okay, I'll listen to it properly because my fucking u-block is like killing
The youtube like you ruined the wholesome moment
Like I didn't expect a random teardrop to like
Triangulate its way onto her face. Okay, she be is making a room. So we're gonna redirect into she be
Um, thank you to who said that she might possibly do a pop-up. Um
Literally, I did not expect that teardrop. I think because of the serious nature kind of of the stream as well
It made it just like extra hilarious
Um, her face had to literally be on top
I think it was just the angle that the tear would have had to have been to hit her face
And like it was such a serious moment
and my brain was like
tear went a little to the left and
That laugh legit lifted my spirits. I'm gonna need to listen to the film
I'll cut it and put on sweater and just be like
POV a tear dropping on an anime girl's face made me burst out laughing for three minutes
because uh, yeah
This strontism hit hard. I literally looked back at it and I was like, it was not that funny. It was not that funny
As much as I like to pretend that I'm funny see he hilarious. It was not that funny
Hey, YouTube keeps making an album
Okay, it looks like
The waiting room is up for shooters
She's reading fanfiction
Uh
Right, okay
Um
Yes, thank you
also much
For the hilarity
That was
The weird yandere anime
I believe if you guys are vouching for for vivi then
It's definitely gonna be a bit better next time around
I do apologize if you found it a distasteful pick
I am ignorant. I mean you can't it's not like you can watch 10 out 10
Anime 10 out 10 all the time. Are you gonna do anime movies? Absolutely. I'm so down to that
Um, she's finishing my immortal Harry Potter fan site. Never seen Vivi so thank you for the stream
I'm really good anime recommend. No, thank you. That was like a hoot holler
And I carry on too. Um, thank you again husky and a 50 mt for the gifted subs
Um
Uh
Let's watch the trashes of trash anime snakes. I don't even think it would be able to hold my like
My attention
Uh, it was great to be honest. The theme was the serving, but I kind of kept me wanting more. Yeah, like to see like how it's gonna go
I definitely think like, you know, you're allowed to consume stuff that is like very oh my god
I would never watch that again type thing, you know
um
uh
Yes, tomorrow we're playing toy knit boy. We're robbing a bakery fling
But as long as we're not robbing from the people
um
Then it's you can rob from the rich but not from the poor
A domestic girlfriend walks along. Whoa. What is that? Wait, is that an anime name? Domestic girlfriend is an anime
Is that real?
Anime or am I I'm I being told
It's a real anime. It's called domestic girlfriend
Domestic girlfriend schoolboy
Nat Sewell's life becomes a whole lot more complicated when he discovers that as soon to be step sibling
It's none other than henna the teacher. He has a crush on and Rui the girl who with whom he has been intimate
I
I don't see a problem with that. I don't see a problem with that anime at all
Don't me kind of
Yeah, really
Domestic girlfriend is you know, that's an actual train wreck and a new
Oh wait niche bros. It's only 12 episodes. Yeah, mommy's gonna watch it
I
Can't say how we call domestic
Do
Ripper friends you see the problem when you watch it real answer what problematic anime is fuck. Yes. I'm me up
Nietzsche Joe is great
I have doomed us all. I'm so sorry everyone
Red line is actually one of the best anime movies of all time made by one guy over seven weeks one guy
So kiss exist
You should kiss your sister and my sister. I mean emmy and by emmy. I mean emmy jimmy bezu from
Jen one indulge veiler
I don't know
You should watch
Okay, I'm going to thank you for the hit in the hauler. I'm gonna make sure I have the link to she be stream
because
Watch like
Frickin redirects are broken chat on screen is broken
Just everything is broken at this point in time. So I'm gonna link her stream just in case. I love emmy bison
You're actually gonna hate it just by the NC if you watch domestic girlfriend come up with suggestions on my absolutely
Manual read let's go literally right. I'm gonna end and if it doesn't automatically read you just click the link I put in the chat
Okay, um, thank you so so much for watching that crazy anime with me
I had no idea what to expect but we did it and it was fun and I enjoyed it and I'm officially certified as a weeb
Yes, I will be commissioning through artwork. No, I will not be taking any other scenes because that was my favorite scene
I don't care. I love a bit blackmail. I love a bit of a bit of uh, you know, uh a bit power play
Well, as long as it's me against you, you know
Um, I'm gonna go for a wee nap and then hopefully there should be some updates updates updates in tm
Thank you so so much
Uh, read flings and enjoy yourselves and I'll see you give the givers tomorrow first robin a bank
I can't believe it when robin bank
Wheat that has reached
Okay, and I give you 12 kisses because there's 12 episodes
Mm-hmm
12 episodes, let's go. Please enjoy she be to your heart's content and I'll see you give the givers tomorrow
Bye